welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host of the
show but for today's episode I'm going
to be joined by a co-host his name is
Greg Knuckles and he's currently the
permanent guest co-host for the time
being Greg thank you for joining me
thanks for having me on how's it going
I'm doing well how are you doing can't
complain
yeah I did uh
it's weird yesterday all day I kind of
felt like I was on vacation
um and this is a free kind of life hack
for anyone who enjoys traveling but you
know maybe you have constraints related
to finances or geography or just kind of
schedule constraints that make it hard
to travel
so what what's your deodorant situation
uh I I use spray deodorant yeah um I I
don't have really any brand loyalty uh
but yeah too much hair down there for
for stick to be my go-to
so I'm a Stick deodorant guy but I do
have brand loyalty big time but to a
certain extent so like my normal
deodorant I wear is like my tried and
true brand but their travel size was
like 50 cents more than the cheapest
travel size and I'm I'm not that loyal
like loyalty always has limits and 50
cents for me is where it I draw the line
so I always smell differently when I'm
traveling like markedly differently and
the other day I ran out of my normal
deodorant and I had to use a travel one
that was sitting around I felt like I
was on vacation all day oh nice it's
crazy like my brain tricks me into
thinking I'm traveling if I just smell a
little bit differently so if if you're
at home and you're like you know what
I'd love a vacation but I don't know if
I can swing it with you know my schedule
or the budget just use a specific travel
deodorant and then every now and then
just bring it out it's like a free
vacation yeah makes sense
um all right so let's see uh if you like
the show
and you want to support it there are
many ways you could do that you could
like rate or subscribe wherever you get
the show uh you could join our email
newsletter which is totally free and we
send out really helpful research
information once a week I think on
Wednesdays the the research review thing
goes out I think so yeah yeah so so we
give these weekly research updates I
believe they go out on Wednesdays but
the newsletter is a really great free
resource check it out at
strongerbyscience.com newsletter if
you're looking for one-on-one virtual
coaching we have a really talented team
of coaches at Stronger by science you
can learn more at Stronger by
science.com coaching if you want to get
an enormous five percent discount off of
your already very fairly priced
supplements go to bulksupplements.com
and use our discount code it is SBS pod
that's SBS pod for a five percent
discount and then of course if you want
to support support the show even more
you could subscribe to the mass research
review which we publish the first of the
month every single month up-to-date
information about the newest research
and exercise in nutrition or you could
check out the macro Factor Diet app
which we co-developed and there is a
free trial for the macro Factor app so
you can take it for a spin and you can
see if you like it anything to add
I don't believe so awesome so this is
going to be a a pretty chill pretty laid
back episode it's going to be a q a
focused episode so we got a whole bunch
of questions and we're just going to go
through and kind of informally address
them it's not going to have the same
degree of
Polish and preparedness that goes into
our lengthy predetermined segments this
is going to be more free-flowing
um and man preparedness is a bit of a
stretch but but we're going to say that
our our typical segments are highly
practiced and curated and thoughtfully
constructed and this is more
free-flowing yeah I definitely uh
practice my segments in the mirror or or
with my wife live audience to give
feedback multiple times before uh before
debuting them on the podcast that's
crazy this will this will be very
different uh than the normal episode in
that regard I was gonna say that's weird
though because that one segment when you
thought it was going to be 20 minutes
and it took like two hours I would have
thought that in your preparation you
would have had some trials where it took
more than 20 minutes yeah no so uh
actually being being completely honest
here's a weird thing about me that not
many people know but now all of our
listeners will know
um
I I can't rehearse things before uh like
before delivering them like like
literally can't I don't know if this is
just like a neurological thing maybe
some sort of like very idiosyncratic
speech disorder but generally I can talk
just fine but if I know on on like a
predetermined basis uh exactly the words
that need to come out of my mouth like
reading a line without uh without like
any room for improvisation I just can't
yeah uh it's like um
um like a severe stammer that I just
can't get over and so I I have I I have
to just have a very loose outline and
all of the words just like come off the
Dome or just like actually just read
like reading words aloud uh if I if I
practice something and I just have in my
head the the precise words in order that
they need to come out uh they will not
exit my mouth I don't think that's weird
at all I'm exactly the same way oh nice
and like I've had situations where
people close to me like know I have a
big presentation coming up and they're
like you know what as a favor I will
volunteer you you can just give me the
presentation before you do it for real
and I'm like I'm absolutely not gonna do
that and they say why and I say because
I care about myself and I want to do
well yeah if I plant in my head that
there is a very specific sequence of
words that should occur I spend the
entire talk trying to find my way to
them and it's ruined yeah like you just
gotta let it flow
um so yeah there's some free uh public
speaking tips so so either we're both
normal or we're both weird in this the
same exact way yeah either way I'm good
with it yeah
um but it does save a lot of time
because you don't have to rehearse it
certainly does yeah all right so let's
jump into some questions some of these
are going to be very very quick some are
going to be more kind of longer
discussions I want to start with a
couple really quick ones just to kind of
knock them out here uh so there was a
question from Keith
um and he asked if medical insulin like
you would have to treat diabetes might
have a performance enhancing effect on
strength and or hypertrophy
um and so at first I thought the answer
to this was was really really really
obvious but it's as the thread of
questions kind of got deeper uh the the
you know the the straightforward
question is can insulin help with
strength or hypertrophy
suprophysiological doses seem to be
helpful for hypertrophy which then of
course eventually will have an impact on
strength at least were of that belief
um and uh yeah so really really really
high doses of insulin uh I don't I don't
know if they're still common in the ifbb
but I know for a while they they really
kind of fueled kind of a new wave of
muscularity when people just it was like
all of a sudden all the top level body
builders got like 15 pounds heavier and
everyone's like hey what happened there
yeah uh my understanding is that insulin
drove part of the one of those big steps
forward in in the ifbb like untested
bodybuilding organ you know where people
are just taking everything you know
um and so yeah just on the most basic
level can insulin help with hypertrophy
yes uh but it is very very extremely
very much dangerous to use insulin at
these super physiological doses just to
get big there are innumerable stories uh
of of people who took a little bit too
much diet uh insulin uh trying to get
some extra hypertrophy you know into
their uh
you know trying to leverage that for
extra hypertrophy and it just you know I
mean insulin doses are not to be messed
around with you know a little too high a
little too low kind of a big deal so uh
it's one of those things that uh
academically I could acknowledge it it
does seem to be helpful for hypertrophy
uh when taking at these huge doses but
man I
it just seems like a horrible idea to me
to be completely honest
um but as the thread kind of went on uh
it sounds like the question is more of
like well no if if I am taking insulin
to treat my diabetes is that type of
dosing going to be helpful for
hypertrophy
um and I would not expect a similar
effect from doses that are intended to
basically just restore normal function
of insulin binding with its receptor and
eliciting the appropriate cellular
response um I would not expect this to
be kind of a
completely linear thing where taking a
little bit of you know a little dosage
for diabetes is pretty good and then a
huge dose is you know is really
hypertrophic
um you know because ultimately when
you're using diabetes and of course this
is not medical advice at all but when
you're using um insulin to treat
diabetes you're trying to restore
function uh you know so for example with
type 2 diabetes you have plenty of
insulin around but you know the the
sensitivity of The receptors is impacted
so you have to kind of introduce some
additional insulin in order to get the
um the necessary cellular response in
terms of insulin binding to its receptor
so what when you're using medical
insulin or with type one like you're
just not producing insulin in the first
place yeah yeah so so type one again is
type one is just you you don't make
insulin right so you you need to
introduce it exogenously type 2 is when
you might say well I already have
insulin in my body and now I'm going
higher so this is you know maybe that's
where we're going to see some of this
hypertrophy but again the only reason
the insulin dose is going higher is
because you're not having that same
level of relationship that you're not
getting that Cascade of events where
insulin appears in the blood binds to
the receptor and initiates that Cascade
of cellular responses so the short
answer is uh I wouldn't expect to see
any meaningful effect on strength or
hypertrophy within that dosing range
insulin fluctuations within the
physiological range don't really seem to
impact much at all in terms of
hypertrophy and once again insulin is
just too too serious to be messing
around with like if you're taking
insulin for diabetes you absolutely
should be getting you should be working
with a clinically trained Medical
Professional on that and should not be
deviating whatsoever from the
instructions that you get there and then
yeah when it comes to the kind of
Anything Goes bodybuilding approach to
insulin I find that to be just extremely
dangerous from from my limiting limited
knowledge of the topic yeah just two two
little things to add one uh being
potentially somewhat hypocritical but
but going with like the Dare uh Scared
Straight approach to drugs
um so I I don't want to make it sound
like I was I was best friends with this
person but I I knew someone like a
friend of a friend's situation
um like I'd met them before but you know
I wasn't like their best their best
buddy or anything but uh yeah untested
bodybuilder uh using exogenous insulin
and uh you know
use some after a workout uh as he was
just like sitting in the drive-through
line at McDonald's to get his
post-workout Meal which was supposed to
include like a larger super-sized Coke
like for you know the the sugar that the
insulin was going to act on
um and the the fast food worker
accidentally gave him Diet Coke and he
died
um so like that's the
that is the sort of thing that can
happen when you're when you're uh
dealing with exogenous insulin in a
non-medical like non-supervised capacity
like of of all of the drugs untested
bodybuilders do uh with a decent degree
of regularity I think insulin is
probably the most dangerous one like
it's it's not something to be trifled
with yeah and like
I all like I don't hang out with a lot
of people who do untested bodybuilding
it's not like uh not saying I wouldn't
but it's just not my my Social Circle
that I currently maintain like I don't
have a high level experience where I'm
in a gym where like every other person
has taken all sorts of stuff uh you know
nothing against it it's just not the gym
in uh culture environment that I that I
grew up in but even I knew someone who
nearly died messing around with insulin
it was actually uh someone that I worked
with and they uh they started using
insulin and they were like oh they were
I mean they're really excited about it
because they're like I heard this is
going to make me huge they got really
impatient with it because after like
three days of using it they weren't huge
yet yeah and they started messing around
with the dose and
yeah one day they just took an enormous
dose uh very ill-advised and just hit
the deck yeah and just like severe
hypoglycemia severe hypoglycemia
couldn't really move and uh as he tells
the story when he just like collapsed uh
there was one of those little plastic uh
you know the individually wrapped
oatmeal cookie cakes with the cream in
the middle yeah yeah
um it's like Little Debbie makes them I
think
um he just so happened to be literally
within biting distance of one of those
and he couldn't like use his arms he
like gnawed through the wrapper laying
on the floor and got enough sugar out of
that thing that uh it helped him pull
through yeah but dude that [ __ ] scares
me yeah it's it's scary stuff so that
that was the that was the first thing I
wanted to say just to add some color to
something you'd already said um the
second thing is I think that
um
I think that the Assumption some people
have that uh using insulin like like
using exogenous insulin for medical
purposes might still have some ergogenic
effects I suspect that that probably
comes from thinking in analogies with a
comparison to trt
um because like this this isn't proven
but there are some
some I think like pretty reason pretty
reasonable like bases to assume that uh
that trt might have some advantages uh
even like above and beyond just like
normal testosterone production in just
like the normal physiological range
which is one reason why like uh a lot of
sports will give you a t-u-e a
therapeutic use exemption for most drugs
that are prescribed to you for
legitimate medical purposes and uh trt
is like a very legitimate medical
purpose to be prescribed a drug in this
case testosterone but like a lot of
sporting events will say like yeah like
we we don't do tues for trt and one of
the reasons for that well two of the
reasons for that is like one
um especially if like what your doctor
prescribed to you is a pretty long
lasting Ester
um like the the day after like two three
days after the injection and you might
be at like actual super physiological
testosterone levels that you know then
drop off into the normal physiological
range and you might wind up near the
bottom of the normal physiological range
before your next injection but like you
do still spend maybe a little bit of
time with super physiological
testosterone levels that might be
ergogenic it's hard to say and then the
other factor is that like especially if
you're competing in bodybuilding or or
even like a lighter weight class in
power lifting where it might be
beneficial to cut get really lean for
your weight class whatever
um one of the things we've talked about
on the podcast before is just like the
hormonal effects of dieting and getting
quite lean and like one of those is just
like a pretty pretty Market reduction in
testosterone uh production and so if
you're on trt
um you know a lot of the other hormonal
effects of cutting and getting that lean
will still be there like the drops in
leptin drops in thyroid hormone Etc up
but you effectively don't have to worry
about tests anymore like you can get
very shredded and still have normal test
levels which
people who aren't using exogenous tests
wouldn't have access to so like there
there are reasons to think that like
even very legitimate medical uses of
testosterone might still at least at
least on the fringes have some net
ergogenic effects
um and so I think people just assume
that insulin would be kind of the same
way but I I don't think it would be
largely because
um like if you're using insulin it has
to be matched to what you're eating and
so you know again if we're not talking
about using huge doses as a bodybuilder
but just like a type 1 diabetic using
insulin to you know replace the insulin
their body isn't producing for the
normal amount of stuff they're eating
um like it is it is still like a
scenario where you're you're you're
matching the input insulin with like
what you're actually eating it's not
like there there's not the same sort of
like decoupling scenario where say with
trt you can be shredded but still have
like high testosterone levels like if
you're if you're a type 1 diabetic and
like you're cutting uh where if you
weren't a type 1 diabetic like insulin
production would be low because like
you're just not eating as much it's the
same thing like you're not eating as
much because you're cutting and so you
just wouldn't be using as much insulin
so like it's it's a it's a more like
tightly coupled thing of like your
body's overall physiological state to
the hormone you're injecting whereas you
can have like a bit of decoupling with
with uh trt treatment yeah there there's
one other thing to address here which is
in that thread somebody pointed out the
fact that uh you know there are a lot of
very very very strong people who happen
to have type 2 diabetes uh who who uh
use insulin medically and they were
wondering if perhaps there's some kind
of observational correlation there and I
would speculate uh that that is a
correlation
that does not follow a causal chain
where you would say oh because I
developed diabetes and got access to
exogenous insulin now I'm much stronger
I think usually people who are just
interested in being really effing big
and strong and aren't really worried
about staying lean It's Not Unusual to
expect that a lot of people who are
pushing and like let's say that your
goal is to be just an absolutely
incredible record-setting super
heavyweight strength strength athlete
that might be a road that leads to uh
pre-diabetes or even a diabetes
diagnosis
um but but the fact that there's insulin
in the mix after that is is a
correlation that is not going to have a
causative factor in terms of you
becoming really F and big and strong
yeah yeah uh all right another question
here from Michael this one's going to be
really short just because we've covered
it a lot and sometimes I'm of two minds
about this where it's like if we've
covered it a lot do I want to make the
the audience suffer through it again
um but I also think that it is important
to have some repetition and content just
because not every person is going to
listen to every moment of this podcast
or or check you know catch every article
that we write uh so the question was why
is a maintenance phase important after
bulking or cutting and physiologically I
don't believe it is and we've kind of
talked through the logic on that uh many
times before in many different uh you
know pieces of content written audio
Etc I don't think that there is a
physiological need or even a
physiological benefit of saying I have
to commit to a maintenance phase after a
bulking phase or a cutting phase for
example if you're someone who's just
kind of taking that incremental approach
where you're going to bulk until you're
you know until you say I'd like to be a
little leaner you know for you know
maybe there's a health biomarker that
you're keeping your eye on or maybe it's
just you know I don't really like how I
look Beyond a particular you know level
of adiposity if you're doing the repo
the repeated bulking and cutting uh
cycles and hoping to just continue
getting more muscular over time uh I
don't see any reason why you'd have to
go bulk to maintenance to cut to bulk to
maintenance to cut you can just bulk cut
a little bit bulk cut a little bit it I
I don't see any physiological downside
to that if there is any value to um
uh you know introducing these
maintenance phases it is uh purely due
to preference and practicality you know
and one of the things you know of course
if you just want to maintain for a while
without making your next really focused
push that that's a very viable reason to
say I'm going to maintain for a while
and just kind of get comfortable at this
weight
um another thing logistically sometimes
a maintenance phase makes it easy to
assess some of the early changes in
scale weight where you know if you're
bulking really hard and just absolutely
eating like crazy and then you go
straight into a really aggressive cut
you're going to convince yourself that
you lost like eight pounds of muscle in
the first couple weeks and sometimes it
is easier uh to deal with the numbers uh
in a more sensible way if you say I'm
going to take like a two or three week
break there where I just kind of
maintain I'm not eating pounds and
pounds and pounds and pounds of food
every day I kind of level off body
weight and then I ease into my cut from
there so there are some reasons why one
might want to do it it but they are not
uh there's there's no physiological
advantage that I I see a lot of evidence
for no yeah I I agree with all of that
all right now let's get into the fun
stuff this is a question we've answered
before in different iterations but it's
a question that's easy to come back to
because uh I feel like every time I
answer this I'm in a slightly different
state of mind I'm in a slightly
different place in my fitness journey uh
you know you can never be in the same
river twice as what they say you know
things are always changing so sometimes
it's it's nice to revisit this with just
a little bit of different context so
Michael asks what are your most
controversial Fitness opinions that
would rile up the evidence-based Fitness
Community
um and I think when I look at my answers
I think controversial is probably
overstating it a little bit but I don't
know I've never been one with with
content to really take huge swings I I
try to just say oh let's try to be as
compatible as possible with the evidence
and when when there's room for some uh
some ad-libbing because there's a gap in
the literature you fill it with you know
some of those more uh anecdotal pieces
of evidence so
um one of the things we've mentioned
previously is uh the old John Meadows
tip of doing hamstring curls before your
squats and uh we've talked about it
before I don't know why it's good but it
sure feels nice I agree it just does
um
I was thinking about a couple things
that I could say from me
um
one of them I did a whole segment on
recently which is I think that as time
has gone on the optimal protein range
within evidence-based Fitness is
approached way too rigidly and way too
dogmatically like we've talked about how
common it is for people to really bulk
if you recommend that someone eats 1.4
grams per kilogram of protein and in any
other
nutritional Niche that is categorically
viewed as a high protein intake in
evidence-based Fitness it's viewed as
like barely enough to survive for some
reason yeah and when you get back to the
actual Source material from which we do
we derive that kind of broadly accepted
optimal range the level of precision is
not what it's made out to be in this
evidence-based Fitness community so my
uh unwillingness to rigidly identify
that exact same protein range I think is
uh bucks the norm a little bit
uh another one that came to mind is
mindful eating for weight loss purposes
um now mindful eating is not for weight
loss and I want to be really clear about
that it's not something that is uh it's
not something that I misunderstand
that's not lost on me the purpose of
mindful eating is not to lose weight
um but there still is evidence looking
at do people happen to lose weight when
they utilize mindful eating strategies
that evidence is mixed there are some
studies indicating yeah there's maybe a
a very slight passive reduction in body
weight other studies saying that didn't
do anything at all people continue
eating the way they normally eat
um I have found personally that when I
do more very intentional mindful eating
my energy intake tends to passively go
down and uh I think part of that is just
kind of mentally reframing the meal I
think part of that is uh strategically
taking emotional elements out of the
eating process and I think part of it's
just eating more slowly uh because it's
really hard to scarf down a meal and do
mindful eating they're pretty mutually
exclusive yeah uh so I I for me mindful
eating has had an outsized impact on
passive weight loss when I compare it to
what I would expect from the literature
another area where I've seen that
is
using sauna for appetite management and
this is not a recommendation because
like with sauna you don't want to just
lock yourself in there recklessly like
sauna something that should be
approached with a high degree of caution
uh and with a really good plan in place
because heat exposure you know humans
are subject to hyperthermia it's one of
one of the things that can get us yeah
so you got to be careful about that but
I started doing sauna just because I
like it it makes me feel good and uh
what I you and I have talked about this
off air maybe on air as well I'm not
certain but I noticed that like I would
have an acute suppression of appetite
after I was in the sauna but I would not
experience uh
a kind of rebound later in the day like
it's not like my appetite would plummet
for three hours and then I would just do
a bunch of ketchup eating you know six
hours later where the you know the the
appetite comes back and then some uh so
what I found was kind of when I do a lot
of sauna I have this acute reduction of
appetite that maybe lasts a couple hours
but then it just goes back to normal
rather than having some kind of
compensatory increase above Baseline uh
I've seen some
I don't even want to use the word
evidence I have seen people hinting at
such effects in the literature but very
in a very tangential Manner and not with
a lot of really strong experimental
evidence supporting it yeah so I've seen
Whispers The the way the place I've seen
this is
people talking there's a great review
paper looking at different elements of
appetite regulation in response to
various physiological stressors uh and
you know they were talking about how
does exercise impact appetite how does
Sauna how does uh coal exposure uh and
actually I don't even know if they
talked about sauna I just know they
talked about core temperature and they
they speculated that some of the acute
appetite suppression from exercise is
due to an elevation of heat production
uh and core temperature
so is there something there I don't know
but it's certainly not a claim that I
would make and say hey here's a very
evidence-based statement but for me it
kind of kind of does some stuff uh and
then one thing that I think would be
kind of controversial if I ever bothered
to lay it out as a hot take and like
really quantify it
is that I can look at the meta-analyzes
and say okay you know here's where
volume appears to start becoming
Superfluous you know either across a
week or within a session you know here's
the set volume that looks reasonable
here's the frequency that looks
reasonable I get all that
but the periods of my life where I've
experienced the most short-term muscle
growth is when I do specifically the
push-pull legs kind of split
and I just throw all the junk volume in
there and and like I'm doing these sets
and I say I know I've seen the
meta-analysis this is supposed to be
unproductive junk volume but every time
I do this [ __ ] I grow
like a pretty it's like a pretty
pronounced thing for me so like
whatever I I'm not trying to like make
it a generalizable statement but man
when I do push pull legs and just say
I'm gonna lock myself in the gym for 90
minutes and just do sets yeah I [ __ ]
grow a lot dude yeah like it it's kind
of a thing that I've noticed
too many times in my lifting career to
ignore it you know so I I think I'm
definitely one of those people who for
me the optimal weekly volume is much
higher than the kind of bare minimum of
the range that you'll see in the
meta-analyzes
uh and that's all I got no yeah I mean
that that all that all checks out
especially what you mentioned about the
sauna like I I don't
um I don't regularly sauna bathe but I
I've also noticed that uh when I'm just
overheated in general like if I think I
noticed this the most when I have a lot
of just like outdoor work I need to do
in the summer
um I I just have no desire to eat and
really no appetite until I eat until I
get cooled off again uh and and then it
is like very similar to what you're
describing like I feel appropriately
hungry but it's not like when I get cold
when I get cold uh like that also
acutely suppresses appetite but then
once I warm up I just want to eat
everything in sight no um the uh I don't
know if you ever looked at that paper
because I know I linked it in a previous
show that that experience is fully
supported by the evidence there is
significant rebounding of appetite after
cold exposure yeah but with with heat
exposure like my my experiences is very
similar to yours yeah
um so my three things that I think might
cause some controversy uh the first is
just kind of like a pedantic point I
guess uh but whatever that's that's
fully within my wheelhouse
um I very frequently see the claim made
that uh it from evidence-based Fitness
professionals that BCAAs Branch chain
amino acids are completely worthless as
a supplement all you're doing is wasting
your money they have you know no utility
whatsoever and the thing is like that's
just fully contradicted by the research
uh so the
the extent to which that is potentially
true is that
um
all of the things that BCAAs are
supposed to do for you protein itself
does for you so if you're consuming
adequate levels of protein uh in an in
especially you have some protein in your
system in or around a workout
um yeah like you're probably not going
to get much from BCAAs although that's
still kind of an open question because
um they're just like aren't studies
directly comparing protein in BCAAs
looking at kind of acute effects uh
which which does interest me like I'm
I'm surprised that those studies haven't
been done but at this point there are
like three or four meta-analyzes that
have been published comparing BCAAs
versus placebos
um looking at kind of like acute
recovery stuff so recovery of muscle
performance uh markers and muscle damage
like soreness uh like inflammation
markers and I mean compared to placebos
BCAAs do seem to have positive effects
and so you know the the claim itself
complete waste of money does nothing is
just categorically false and then the
more practical claim of like well you
know why don't you just do protein
instead
um like I think that that's fair in most
contexts like if if you're say working
out after work after school whatever
um you've already eaten breakfast and
lunch you're gonna eat dinner later then
like yeah like I I would be very
surprised if you did benefit from
consuming BCAAs during or around your
workout but if you're someone who say
trains first thing in the morning and uh
you know like speaking for myself I
don't want to drink a protein shake
immediately before or during a workout
and I also just don't like protein
shakes I think they're nasty
um and like some BCAAs like actually
taste kind of nice and so if you train
in the morning and like you just don't
want to chug approach protein shake in
or around your workout and maybe you're
doing intermittent fasting you're not
going to eat until lunch like I think in
that scenario
um you should you should very reasonably
expect positive effects of BCAAs so yeah
like I think that
I think that they are absolutely
oversold in like the marketing material
attached to them um but I I also think
that pendulum has swung too far back the
other side where people just say ah they
do nothing complete waste of money in
all contexts and like that's just not
true yeah I I you mentioned the the um
the special case of training in the
morning uh lately I've been waking up
very early and just like rolling out of
bed and going straight to the gym and so
like I'm I'm drinking my morning coffee
while I'm working out and just kind of
using it as as a way to like wake up
because I've noticed that it's just for
my daily schedule it's so much so much
better I'm more reliably get my workouts
and have enough time for them if I just
do it first thing like just nothing else
comes up uh but man people in my gym
when they see me I kind of like
permanently look like that have you ever
seen that Meme with uh with Ben Affleck
when he looks like he's reached a level
of tired that is hard to put into words
you know just
spiritually tired is it
is it the one where he's holding the
cigarette yeah if he's not holding a
cigarette he's spiritually holding a
cigarette I think he is holding a
cigarette and he just looks like he's
dead inside and is tired as a person
could be yeah and that's pretty much how
I look when I'm when I'm working out
these days it's a great you got it
pulled up can you uh angle it at me
there
is this the one oh yeah yeah he's just
he's he's really going through he's
really going through it he and I both
I'm just over there leaning on the uh
the belt squat machine with my coffee
like God I can't believe I'm here yeah
uh but anyway yeah so go on uh so number
two is
I I think that uh people in the
evidence-based Fitness Community might
oversell the the difficulty of training
to failure at least as far as like
recovery burdens go so
um
there there's plenty of research you
could cite that just takes an acute
design where you have one group trained
to failure one group not trained a
failure and then look to see recovery
afterwards uh or like a crossover design
where you know a group of subjects
trains to failure or not you know wash
out period four to six weeks and then
they kind of flip flop and again just
look to see a cute recovery responses uh
creatine kinase creatinine soreness
levels uh recovery of contractile Force
Etc and it is it is very much true that
in those studies you tend to see a
longer time course of recovery when
people train to failure but then I think
people uh over extrapolate from that
considerably and they say like wow if
you uh train a single muscle to failure
every week or every time you train that
muscle there's no way you're going to be
able to recover from it you're just
going to accumulate like a huge fatigue
debt and basically just [ __ ] die and
the thing is like one
that is like you can't draw that
inference from the studies that have
been done uh because they don't include
like inadequate habituation phase and
that's important because like if you
look at
if you look at just about any training
intervention that is like more intense
or challenging than what the subjects
are accustomed to and this is like
especially true if it's a study on
untrained subjects
um I mean you might see a Time course of
recovery that's like three four five
days up to a week maybe even longer for
like particularly uh cruel eccentric
training protocols but then I mean
people listening to this who lift
weights I'm sure you remember the first
time you lifted weights you were just
absolutely murdered for for a week maybe
even longer and then guess what now you
do the same workout again and it doesn't
affect you as much
um and there there's every reason to
suspect that they that that same sort of
habituation uh and and that application
of the repeated bout effect would apply
to training to failure as well
um and so like one yeah uh an acute
study that only involves like a single
bout of training to failure and looking
at the recovery time course after that
bout
I don't think we should necessarily
assume that that will always be the
recovery time course for someone who
consistently trains to failure the other
thing to note is just the like
on on a more metal level if you if you
read a lot of research like a lot of
longitudinal resistance training studies
I would say I would say most if not most
somewhere around half of the training
protocols used in the research are just
yeah you're gonna do like six sets to
failure on a particular muscle group two
or three times a week like that's that
is the go-to training prescription
um where you know you might start with
like 70 75 percent of one RM uh one or
two exercises you're doing three to five
sets to failure and uh the rep range
they're going for is eight to twelve and
once you can complete 12 reps on all of
the sets weight goes up the next week
but it's just training to failure like
every session every week for like 10 to
12 weeks and guess what people get
bigger they get stronger they don't all
over train and [ __ ] die and get
injured
um so like yeah it like I I don't want
to
um imply that the opposite is true and
that
um training to failure doesn't ever come
with an increased recovery burden and
you know even once you fully habituate
to it it may still have a greater
recovery burden than non-failure
training but I I think people just just
blow that way out of proportion and and
make it seem like much much scarier and
harder to recover from than it really is
yeah I know you definitely hear from
people who are like listen there's no
way that you could do a set of bicep
curls to failure on Wednesday
and do another one to failure on
Saturday yeah it's it's not within the
range of human possibilities and uh
it actually is
it certainly is uh and then the third
thing this is kind of Half Baked I might
do a full segment on this at some point
but it's it's something that I've been
kind of stewing on for a while and it
relates to mechanisms of hypertrophy
um so I think that I think that a good
chunk of evidence-based Fitness folks
have fallen into what I would call a
trap of tension reductionism so just for
some background on this
um man a long time ago at this point
maybe like 2010 uh Brad schoenfeld
published a paper
um laying out what appeared to be at the
time the main mechanisms of muscle
hypertrophy and uh what he came up with
was mechanical tension metabolic stress
and muscle damage and then in the
subsequent years
started looking uh much more like
it doesn't seem like metabolic stress is
uh as important as we previously
believed it to be maybe not really
important at all
um muscle damage also like the the case
for it um seemed to weaken over time and
so uh effectively of those three we were
left with mechanical tension being the
one that had the most support and a a
growing amount of support and then uh so
a few years after the show and filled
paper there was a paper by uh hitting
whacker Hage and colleagues I'm probably
pronouncing that wrong but whatever uh
the title was something along the lines
of like uh
it was like initiators of muscle
hypertrophy something like that like
initiators and mechanisms of muscle
hypertrophy yeah it's like a
collaborative project where they
basically Revisited yeah like Sean
feld's 2010 project and almost kind of
like provided an update yeah yeah and so
the the basic takeaway from that paper
was that like yeah mechanical tension
does seem to be the the primary
initiator of the cellular processes that
kick off the process of muscle
hypertrophy
um but I think people have taken that to
a bit of an unjustifiable extreme to the
point of
assuming that tension is the only thing
that matters uh and not only is it the
only thing that matters
um also just like a tacit assumption
that there is a direct linear
relationship between the amount of
tension that your muscle fibers are
exposed to and the amount of muscle
hypertrophy that will be experienced
um and then also like like taking it to
the extreme of essentially saying like
hey if we do a thought experiment
um like any sort of training
modification that will increase tension
will necessarily increase hypertrophy
and if a study is published where it
doesn't seem like the intervention would
have affected mechanical tension but you
still see a difference in muscle
hypertrophy that must be a completely
spurious finding because there's nothing
else that could be contributing other
than tension
um and so yeah like I think that I think
a lot of that has been has been taken to
a pretty a pretty unjustifiable extreme
by some folks
um and just like a few things to note
about it
is one
um
like there are
there are assumptions that seem to be
like baked in to a lot of that that I
don't think there's data to support so
so like for example
um it's kind of assumed that if you take
a set to failure uh all of your fibers
at some point during that set would have
been exposed to the maximum tension that
those fibers would be capable of being
exposed to
um and like
there's one there's there's not good
data to directly support that like you
you would need like it's it's very hard
to study fibers in Vivo like most of
most of like the very direct fiber
research like you have to do uh a biopsy
and separate out the fibers and I cook
them up to very uh very like nuanced
equipment to actually like study that
stuff
um like it's it's hard to even pick out
like activation of individual fibers
like you can use high density EMG to get
at that but
um that that's not going to be able to
perfectly decompose activation rate
coding like all of that stuff and so
like yeah like we we don't have direct
evidence for that and there's also like
theoretical uh
some theoretical models suggesting that
like that's probably not the case so
there was
um a great paper by potvin and
colleagues uh that is linked in my
article on Stronger by science about
effective reps if you want to check that
out but yeah like it seems like other
than just like maximum like like
completely maximum isometric
contractions a lot of your motor units
probably don't actually reach tension in
the first place but they still seem to
grow just fine so yeah like
to be clear mechanical tension is very
important and I think of all of the
things that can contribute to
hypertrophy based on what we know it is
probably the most important factor but I
I think that there's
um some willingness to take that to a a
very unjustifiable extreme to say not it
is the most important factor but in fact
it is the only Factor uh then also with
like a secondary assumption that there's
just like a purely linear dose response
relationship between the tension the
fiber is exposed to and how much
hypertrophy it experiences like yeah a
lot of that like we we just don't have
data to support yet
um
so yeah I I I think that that would
probably uh get me in hot water with
some folks yeah I mean I think the kind
of prevailing theme here
um for many of these things is that
there is kind of a natural tendency to
want or to gravitate toward uh kind of
oversimplified understandings of some of
these topics and to place a really high
degree of confidence in those simplified
narratives uh you know so for like
Branch chain amino acids categorically
useless and I'm very confident in it
right that's kind of like a common thing
that you see uh optimal protein range
1.6 to 2.2 and we know this with
certainty to due to the advancements of
uh Science and Mathematics like a lot of
times it's just like we lose that layer
of nuance that that is probably pretty
important to retain yeah all right so uh
before we move on to our next question
question I think we should probably take
a moment to sell out it's a very
important part of the show so we're
going to take a quick timeout for an
obscene profit break
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than protecting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul proprietor
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in a applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
alright so back to the questions and
hopefully some answers I've got one
question here I'm going to address very
very quickly it was from George and then
there were some additional commentary
from Jason but but basically the
question was uh you know I'm not
preparing for a bodybuilding show or
anything like that kind of a casual
lifter just kind of really into fitness
I'm doing a cut and the question is how
important is it to maintain most of your
muscle on a cut
um and and basically their perspective
uh kind of oversimplifying a bit is
whatever I'll just cut and if I happen
to lose some muscle you know muscle
memory Etc I'll just make it back the
next time that I do some kind of a
bulking attempt
um and ultimately you know as I was
reading this question I mean as far as
I'm concerned this is a 100 percent
subjective thing uh how important is it
uh it that that's a question that I
would send right back to you uh it
really comes down to your preferences
your priorities so how important is
muscle retention in a non-clinical
scenario it just depends on how much
muscle you want to have at any given
point in time so
um I don't think that there's actually
an objective like scientific answer to
this I think in the interest of being
efficient with your efforts it's
probably not a bad idea to do at least
the bare minimum to to try to maintain
muscle if you can during a cut so you
don't want to go
outrageously huge with your deficit you
don't want to go outrageously low with
your protein and you want to make sure
that you're doing some resistance
training even if you're cutting your
volume and your overall effort in the
gym by it by a sizable amount you still
want to do something to try to maintain
that now
how much effort you put into
optimization again that's where we start
getting into simply a matter of
preference and priority uh but I will
note this
um anecdotally in my experience
people who lift seem to have a tendency
to overestimate the amount of muscle
that they lose while cutting
um I I think there's a couple things
that go into that and to be clear I'm
not judging because this has 100 been me
I have been in this position where I've
very much overestimated my muscle loss
on a cut I think a couple things feed
into that first of all we do have a
tendency to underestimate how much fat
Mass we have prior to weight loss uh I
mean this is like a it's so cliche in
the bodybuilding World talk to a
first-time competitor and say how much
weight do you think you're going to have
to lose to be stage ready if they say 20
pounds it's 40. if they say 30 it's 50.
like there when I did my first show I
was like man if I get down to like 165 I
might die but I'll be shredded and when
I got to 155 I was like I'm not even
close like I'm not even close to ready
so that's one thing that goes into it is
there is this tendency to to
underestimate fat Mass before a cut
um another part is just good
old-fashioned catastrophizing which I've
I've definitely been guilty of but you
know you start to see the scale weight
go down and you're someone who's been
really into getting big for many years
and you say uh oh that looks kind of bad
like I I always thought of myself as
being someone who weighs 200 pounds so
why does the scale say 170. you know you
start to get some of these ideas in your
head where you're like man I'm I'm just
absolutely wasting away the shirts where
you used to look huge you start to look
less huge in them you know so I think
those two things really predispose a lot
of lifters myself included to kind of
overestimate our muscle loss during a
cut and in many cases uh you know when
you lose weight a considerable amount of
weight and you're a lifter you know you
you're probably going to lose some
fat-free mass in the process to what
extent is it muscle it kind of depends
but um but yeah I do think we have a
broadly a tendency to overestimate that
yeah no I I agree I I don't have
anything to add all right well here's a
question that I think you will have
plenty to add uh after I take a crack at
it so there's a question from Anthony
and the question is all about NSAIDs
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
the question reads is there a proper way
of training and using NSAIDs when in
need I've heard that for older
individuals they can be beneficial but
how does application change when you're
a younger individual who is in momentary
need of NSAIDs for sickness or some
other kind of minor health issue
um so that the person in this scenario I
I guess is
um experiencing a high degree of
systemic inflammation and therefore is
is leaning on these uh to answer this uh
I lean on two sources here one is kind
of leaning on the general principles of
the antioxidants article that I did a
couple years back stronger by
science.com
antioxidants so leaning on some of the
the principles and the kind of
philosophical underpinnings of that
literature and then cross-referencing
with a recent paper by uh gergic which
was about
ibuprofen and uh muscle hypertrophy is
that how you say it when I was growing
up my mother always said ibuprofen but
when I whenever I look at it it's it's
ibuprofen I've never heard a person say
it that way uh my mom also said
ibuprofen uh I think it's ibuprofen yeah
I just I've never heard anyone actually
pronounce it the way it's written uh
Lindsay and her family do wow and I I
picked that up are they chemists uh no
they're they're also Ohio people wow
there are Chemists in Ohio but but yeah
I get what you're saying uh but anyway
ibuprofen looking at hypertrophy
outcomes and in gurgix review
um there are basically two things that
come to mind in terms of key moderating
factors first of all uh as the question
hinted at elderly population versus
younger population
the other Factor was dose and so to
paint with really broad Strokes first of
all there's not a lot of research in
this area there's some but not a ton
painting with broad Strokes it looks
like I there is some evidence that
Ibuprofen can actually be helpful for
hypertrophy in older individuals but
that it might blunt hypertrophy in
younger individuals when it's taken at
high doses and that is extremely
reminiscent of the findings and the
antioxidant literature where uh with
antioxidants really high dose stuff can
actually potentiate possibly hypertrophy
for older individuals and there is some
pretty overstated evidence that it might
have some blunting effect in in younger
individuals and the reason that age
matters there is because as we get older
a lot of times we experience increases
in systemic inflammation that's kind of
a Hallmark of the aging process so um
basically when we kind of lean on some
of the antioxidant literature which is
of course highly related to this kind of
idea of systemic inflammation and
oxidative stress when we lean on the
emerging evidence related to ibuprofen I
would say uh
it's you probably don't want to go out
of your way to use huge doses of of
NSAIDS on a super regular basis I think
if it's a short-term period where you're
using them because you've been medically
directed to use them I wouldn't lose a
lot of sleep over that if there is a
blunting effect in the context of you
know really substantial inflammation
it's probably pretty minimal uh and and
if you're using it like 1200 milligrams
per day is usually about as high as a
dose you're going to take with
over-the-counter ibuprofen a lot of
these studies you know when they're when
they're studying like 400 milligram
doses per day they're not seeing really
much of anything once they get up to
1200 then you're starting to see
something but it's also in young people
who have no reason to be taking you know
they don't have the systemic
inflammation that would indicate that
they should have been taking that in the
first place so I think the main modifier
here is the level of inflammation and
the dosage basically yeah I I agree and
and just in Practical terms
[Music]
um
I I think that one it's worth keeping
study design in mind like the I I
haven't looked back at the study uh in a
while but if memory serves the the young
adults taking a high dose of ibuprofen
they were taking it after every workout
over like six to 12 weeks or something
like that yeah and they did still
experience hypertrophy but like using a
high dose of ibuprofen after every
workout I think reduced hypertrophy by
somewhere between like 50 and two-thirds
like somewhere around there but you know
it didn't completely stop it and that's
that's when using ibuprofen after every
workout
and so you know if if you're sick from
time to time and you're you're taking
NSAIDs to bring down the fever or yeah
you have a headache once a week and you
wanna you wanna pop some ibuprofen to
help with that
um you know that is different from
taking a high dose after every single
workout and so if there is a blunting
effect it would I would strongly assume
not be of the same magnitude observed in
the research
um yeah if you're taking a lower dose
and only occasionally instead of a high
dose after every workout uh you're
probably not going to notice a
difference and if you did it would it
would be minimal
um
and then if you are in a position where
you do feel like you need to take NSAIDs
after every workout because
after every workout you're not just sore
but like [ __ ] like legit hurts
um
what I would probably recommend is uh
try to sort that out
um like that that seems to be a greater
concern than the fact that you're using
NSAIDs like the fact that you need to
use NSAIDs after every single workout
um you know suggests you should maybe
talk to a physical therapist and and try
to get some of that under control yeah
and like you know if you're taking the
NSAIDs because you are just beating the
[ __ ] out of your body in every single
workout you know there could be a
two-pronged approach where you say okay
I'm going to you know really revisit the
way I'm training and scale that back and
do it in a more uh controlled manner in
terms of the the training stimulus but
you could also say well do I need to be
taking
NSAIDs for this or like maybe I scale
back the training I combine it with some
you know really nice you know
phytonutrients that reduce you know
oxidative stress and inflammation maybe
you say should I really be taking like
eight Ibuprofen a day or should I like
maybe have some tart chariot extract or
cherry juice that I drink as kind of a
short-term solution to get through
really intensive training periods but
like that's something I talk about every
time I review a supplement in Mass
that's supposed to help with uh recovery
like it is valuable to know what helps
for that but like even when I'm
reviewing the tart cherry stuff I'm like
you shouldn't need this as like a 365
day a week thing to get through your
training like if you're leaning on it to
get through training camp and it's like
a two or three week period of time where
stuff's just crazy I get it but yeah if
you're in a position where you need
really really effective ergogenic aids
to help you get just recovered from your
day-to-day training sessions you got to
revisit those training sessions yeah
all right uh moving on here uh we've got
a question Greg how would you pronounce
that name wout woot I would assume voot
voot okay yeah voot that that looks good
um this question we're getting very
practical here uh our dumbbell side
raises or lateral raises enough to grow
the lateral aspect of the deltoid
musculature or do you need to do some
kind of shoulder press or upright row to
supplement that in order to maximally
build that like I said that lateral
portion of the deltoid musculature
um I'll say for me anecdotally uh just
from being in the trenches as they say
uh when I'm putting together my
priorities for shoulder muscularity I'm
actually lately not a big overhead press
guy
um it's one of those things I I have a
policy I do not do accessory exercises
that cause even the most minimal amount
of discomfort because there's just so
many different accessory exercises you
can do for hypertrophy I I
philosophically don't think it makes any
sense to to push yourself through an
accessory lift where you're like why am
I doing this if it causes even minor
irritation so uh I've been you know
overhead presses for me I've felt like
they are not really getting my deltoids
the way I'd like and they cause a little
bit of irritation for me so I've been
kind of moving away from a lot of them
the one exception that we've talked
about on the show many I mean it was
probably years ago I do like a good uh
circus dumbbell press because it does
allow me to kind of position my torso so
that with each side that I'm pressing
I'm in a really good comfortable
position that minimizes some of that
discomfort but anyway for me the main
priorities lately for shoulder growth is
doing a bunch of presses at different
angles so doing flat bench press and
then incline you know low Incline High
incline really high incline uh and then
doing a lot of rows at a variety of
angles as well so you know kind of like
a pretty pretty straightforward
horizontal row but then also doing lat
pull Downs that are kind of in that
middle ground between a lat pull down
and a row
um that that's been helping me out a lot
with my shoulders uh and then just as
kind of the icing on the cake I I do a
lot of lateral raise variations and for
me that's been enough so uh getting to
the the root of the question uh you know
do you need to add in shoulder presses
or upright row currently I don't use a
variation of either of them and I really
don't think I'm missing out uh from
omitting those
um and I will say just as a side note
there has been one time in my life where
my deltoids just exploded and looked
enormous I was doing smallav Junior for
the bench press as I'm sure we all have
I mean if you were lifting in 2012 and
you weren't doing doing small op Junior
for your bench press I literally don't
know what you were doing I I didn't are
you kidding me you've never done it no
oh my god dude you should do it I I did
uh I did smolov for bench press just
like the the the norm oh wow yeah I I
like that I like the the junior version
it seemed to be a little bit more
amenable to the bench press for me but I
did it I I was I did it twice because
like you're not they tell you not to but
I I did it took like one week and I was
like hell yeah I'm going back in and
honestly the returns were diminishing
the second time through but not as much
as you'd expect yeah like my bench press
exploded and my deltoids were huge no my
my death by volume program for bench
press was uh like like back in the day
before the chico gold app was out and
and the only uh details of the chico
training methodology were just the
spreadsheets that were kind of floating
around the internet just like random
program he'd given to like random
lifters at some point over the years
um there there was one that was like
specifically for a bench specialist that
just had just outrageous binge volume
and I I did that a few times that was
fun I I just remember you brought me
back to a memory of being such a jackass
where I like found that spreadsheet and
didn't bother to read up on it or look
into it at all and I was just like sweet
uh now I have all the secrets I need to
be uh extremely strong and I didn't
realize that it was kind of intended to
be split up into two sessions but like I
just did what I was told so I would just
like go and squat and then go do some
other [ __ ] and say well I guess I'm
gonna go back and squat again yeah and
like I never even spent a moment
thinking like
why am I doing this like why am I going
and just doing other stuff and then
going back into the same exact squat
rack like 20 minutes later
um but yeah I think I I think I was
talking to somebody like many many years
later and they're like yeah it was
supposed to be your second session of
the day and I was like oh yeah yeah I
get that now yeah
all right uh do you have anything to to
add here with the deltoids oh yeah so I
I've had a very similar experience so
here's some here's some potentially
weapons grade Bro Science but as as
someone who's done a ton of bench press
uh I have very strong front delts and
you know I I haven't uh I haven't gone
to a lab and like had someone hook up
the the EMG to actually like assess my
my muscle activation uh or like relative
muscle usage with overhead press but my
subjective feeling is just that my
friend delts take over like almost
exclusively like I'll like after a high
rep set of shoulder press I'll have a
ridiculous front delt pump and like side
delts just just nothing going on
um so yeah like I for for my shoulder
training I I also uh rely very heavily
on on dealt raises and rows
nice
um
okay uh I'm gonna skip around is there
any question that you feel very uh
enthusiastic about answering here let me
skip around a little bit
let me see in the meantime I'm gonna
answer one about uh ashwagandha here
sure so Peter asks ashwagandha for
strength and hypertrophy yay or nay uh
for strength and hypertrophy I would say
put me down for nay
um whenever I hear people talking about
this
the discussion almost always leads to
one specific paper that I've talked
about I think on the podcast before but
it reported uh strength changes that
were
one way to put it would be large another
way to put it is just like totally
implausible
um not making any specific allegation
but I would be absolutely stunned if
anything close to a replication ever
occurred with that study just the
magnitude effect of the effect was
astronomical
um to the point of being like I don't
really know what I can even do with this
um so ashwagandha for strength and
hypertrophy I don't find the evidence to
be very compelling I don't see enough of
a mechanistic uh rationale where I would
say oh yeah it's going to make you huge
and strong
um but that doesn't mean that
ashwagandha has no uses so like for
example uh evidence pertaining to like
mild anxiety symptoms like I please do
not try to like self-medicate your way
through a psychiatric diagnosis like
this is not I'm not recommending any
anything like that but like as someone
who has had some mild anxiety in the
past there is some research indicating
that ashwagandha can help out with that
a little bit but it's not a a reason to
get off your anxiety meds or anything
like that
there is some evidence linking it to
Sleep Quality which which I do find to
be uh plausible and compelling
um and then one thing is uh testosterone
and you know I kind of have a
my the way I discuss testosterone
supplements I think people might find it
to be like they're like it's a little
bit
um contradictory but it's not there
there's something to it here so when I
talk about testosterone boosters uh like
supplements not exogenous trt when I
talk about test boosters in the realm of
strength and hypertrophy I usually talk
them talk about them uh with a very
skeptical tone just because the
magnitude of effect should be quite
modest right so when we look at
supplement interventions to boost or
support testosterone levels were even in
the most promising uh uh papers you're
seeing increases in the range of around
50 nanograms per deciliter maybe
sometimes you'll see a paper that's like
a hundred
um but we're not seeing these it's not
something that's going to take you from
300 to 950 you know and so the reason
that I kind of downplay test boosters
when I'm talking about strength and
hypertrophy is because people get these
ideas about the magnitude of effect
where they're like okay so trt and
ashwagandha for testosterone same thing
right absolutely not the same thing
magnitudes are completely different but
when I talk about test boosters or test
supporting supplements for things like
subjective vitality and libido I
actually do think that there's enough
room there uh there's there's a really
nice review paper talking about like
where do we draw the line for low test
and what the the paper gets at is the
fact that
the way I feel it 350 you might feel
that way at 280. and someone else might
feel that way it you know 3.95 like
there's this kind of
threshold where when your test
testosterone gets below that threshold
which varies from person to person you
start to feel some of these symptoms
where your subjective energy level and
kind of perceived Vitality starts to
drop off your libido starts to drop off
and I actually do believe that certain
test supporting supplements for test
boosting supplements can be enough to
get you from a little below that
threshold to a little above that
threshold in some context so
um I wouldn't say you know when it comes
to ashwagandha's effects anxiety stuff
sleep stuff that looks relatively
promising to me uh especially the
anxiety stuff the sleep stuff there's
not as much research uh very very very
modest boosts in testosterone there's
some evidence there you know we'll see
how well it replicates in the future but
the studies have been done uh but when
it comes to a notable increase in like
strength and hypertrophy that's where I
start to become very very skeptical yeah
I'm I'm right there with you this is uh
this is a question I've encountered a
few times and I I think you did a good
job of navigating it because like yeah
there is that that one study where if
you take it at face value seems like
ashwagandha might be one of the more
effective ergogenics for people with
strength or hypertrophy goals but
uh yeah there's there's not like a a
direct super plausible mechanism like
like there would be for creatine or
something like that
um so like yeah uh it's certainly
possible that it's really good but I I
would also very very much like to see
that study replicated yeah
foreign
did you find a question that really
speaks to you
um yeah I I liked uh I liked Patrick's
uh near the bottom I also just like
Patrick himself shout out shout out to
Patrick Umphrey uh and if you are
listening to this and you're a Facebook
user and you want to check out a a
fitness group on Facebook that's
um you know nice supportive and not just
like a toxic mess uh check out Patrick's
group it's called
eat train progress I believe yeah uh
it's it's a it's a great community and
he's also
I'll I'm gonna double down on this claim
um you know we talked about kind of
controversial opinions in Fitness
there is not a better magician in the
evidence-based Fitness space than
Patrick oh no doubt and I will double
down on that claim for the rest of my
life yeah okay which one are we going
with because he has two in here
um yeah let's do both let's start with
the first one all right so Patrick asks
um you know he well he says this may not
apply as a as a science Communicator or
educator but he's going to ask us anyway
number one do you ever look back at your
old content and cringe uh and number two
does it make you question whether you're
going to look back at your current
content in the future and cringe uh and
he also has a little caveat there by the
way not implying anything about our old
content
um you want to go first on this one yeah
sure so the the answer to the first
question do I ever look back on on Old
content and cringe is yes absolutely uh
and then second question does that make
you question whether you'll look back on
your current content in cringe yeah
absolutely
um so one of the things that I've become
much more comfortable with over time is
just the fact that like everyone is
wrong about stuff all the time
um yeah and that that's easy to it's
easy to look out at other people and
identify incorrect beliefs they have or
incorrect beliefs that that you perceive
them to have
um but it's I think almost impossible to
reliably do that for yourself because
just in general like if you operate on
the assumption that you know a lot of
the things you know are wrong a lot of
your perceptions are flawed and just
like your mental model of how things
work in a lot of specific domains and
how you interact in the world all of
that's faulty you just you just go
insane like you you you have to go
through life
with the Baseline assumption that you're
basically right about basically
everything basically all the time uh and
that's that's not a novel point I came
up with
um ah man
I didn't read the book but there there
was an article about a book about being
wrong for maybe like three or four years
ago that you listen to a podcast about
an article about a book about being
wrong no I uh I mean so okay here's
here's a diversion
um I don't really read that many
non-fiction books of kind of like that
genre of like Hey we're gonna take a big
idea and just like really dig into it
for like 200 250 pages I used to read a
lot of books like that and I realized
that like the book itself is the first
paragraph or like the first chapter and
then like the last chapter yeah
um and you know like they'll they'll
State their thesis and then most like 80
of the book is just kind of like
Meandering anecdotes that are related to
the thesis but most of the time they lay
the thesis and like the the meatiest
evidence out for the thesis within the
first chapter so like most of it's just
a waste and I find that a lot of the
times if you read like in extended
snippet that people use for press
purposes and then just like watch a
video from or listen to an interview
with the author you lose Nothing by not
reading your book yeah I agree um so
yeah it's that sort of thing but yeah so
when when I encountered that I was like
oh [ __ ] like yeah that's that's
absolutely right
um like I I would have to be I would
have to be extremely arrogant to look
around and like see all of the incorrect
beliefs that I think other people hold
and not say like ah you know what I I'm
probably wrong about like a similar
proportion of of the [ __ ] that I
currently think
um and yeah like uh looking back on my
my own content is a good lens through
which to see that because I I've never
published something that I didn't
believe to be true and well supported at
the time of publication and then I look
back on it I'm like oh yeah like with
with the benefit of hindsight and
learning more and knowing more now
um you know I think like 80 of this
article is good 20 10 just really
[ __ ] wrong I have no idea how I put
that to paper in the first place and the
other 10 uh you know I got wrong for
understandable reasons like there's
better evidence that exists now that
just wasn't available to me at the time
that I wrote this but like yeah I would
definitely frame some of this
differently
um and so like yeah I
um I
as time goes on and I I make content
um I I'm much more comfortable when I
publish something now acknowledging and
understanding that like
a decent chunk of it is probably just
wrong
um but I I try to do my my due diligence
to uh put as few incorrect ideas into
the world as possible and uh ultimately
I think that's just the best you can do
um but yeah no like I I uh like I hope
I'm improving over time but certainly I
I expect that I will also look back on
my work that I put out today in cringe
yeah I think our experiences with this
are similar
um but but there are some key
differences
um because we just took different
trajectories with our careers and stuff
so I kind of committed to like I'm just
gonna put my head down and stay in the
lab for a while before I put out a lot
of like content you know so I don't have
like a huge library of articles that
predated my masters and my PhD and stuff
like that so um for me when I look back
at some of my earliest research projects
I look at them and I say
okay are they terrible no they're not
Dreadful they're not fatally flawed
they're not a curse upon the literature
that needs to be removed from the
literature or anything like that but I
look at them and I say wow I would have
done a lot better today if I if I
started that project
um and that kind of I almost view that
as the
the curse of curiosity and the burden
that you carry when you're committed to
learning new things is like
when I think about researchers who don't
look back at their early work and say
like ah yeah I would do a lot better
today to me that's a in many cases an
indicator you haven't learned a damn
thing in like 25 years yeah you know
like and is that because of uh there's
no incentive to learn new things or is
it because it's a little bit of denial
and if you learn new things then you
have to wrestle with having been wrong
in the past and with Academia there's
not a lot of wiggle room for that
um you know I I there there could be a
number of things that go into it but
yeah for me I don't have a huge library
of
articles that I wrote in like 2013 or
anything like that but when I look back
at my early like you know with with me
like
when I
did my PhD I leaned very hard into I
want to learn more not about necessarily
exercise and nutrition but I want to
learn a lot more about research I want
to dig into methodology statistics
things like that you know they had the
exercise and nutrition stuff is part of
the deal but that's where I really focus
my time and effort and uh man that was
tough sledding because you start kind of
digging into deeper and deeper and
deeper topics and you're like it's not
just that you know some of my earlier
stuff was really superficial and weak
it's that the entire field is being
trained to do things that are pretty
superficial and weak and so in order to
deviate from that there's a lot of
self-instruction that has to occur you
have to like go out and say like all
right well then what is the way that
other fields are doing that doing this
that our field has not yet adopted and
then like man it's really really hard to
kind of force yourself into that type of
like well I guess yes I'll have to try
to seek out resources for this and mess
it up 30 times before I get it right and
and my the prize the thing you get at
the end of the road for that is just
looking back and saying man look at all
those crappy projects I did five years
ago yeah uh so it's a tough sell I'm not
gonna lie but uh but yeah I
when it gets to even just Fitness
content you know I'll still look back at
things I did
um
I think
research in the last three years has
helped me really make sense of how to
frame and contextualize and deal with
metabolic adaptation and I look back at
some of the stuff I wrote maybe three or
four years ago and it's it's all true
but just not framed as effectively as
possible and so it's it's one of the
things I've been trying to work on
lately is like how do we redo some of
this framing in light of new evidence
you know so yeah I used to focus so much
on does it exist and why and not as much
on to what extent does this get between
you and your fitness goals yeah because
does it exist yes why because of reasons
but is it necessarily a huge barrier
actually not really you know and so
trying to unravel that has has been uh
an arduous task for sure no I I agree
and and I think
um I think you you raise a good point
about framing because like when I look
back at Old content the thing that makes
me cringe the most is when I make claim
that I thought at the time had more
support than they did and just as I've
learned more about the scientific
process itself and like reading and
interpreting evidence
um things that I used to think were well
supported I look back on like the body
of research that I was basing beliefs on
before and realized like oh this this
was quite a bit weaker than I thought it
was and if I was writing this article
again the actual conclusions might not
be that different but
um I I I I perceive that I came across
as like a way overconfident blowhard
um and I wouldn't have done that if
writing it today so in in term in terms
of like framing and how I talk about
things
um something that I try to be pretty
pretty intentional about now is uh being
pretty explicit about the type and
strength of evidence that I have to
support things
um
and like essentially being able to say
like hey uh here here are my beliefs
about this particular topic and here's
what it's based on like here here is the
literature at this point in time and if
I'm clicking like publish today uh
here's the state of the research in
November of 2022. this [ __ ] could change
a lot in the future
um so you know whatever I'm saying is
tentative and provisional but here's the
state of the research today and then
that is supplemented by
um here's here are just like the
experiences that I have related to this
topic
um I'm sure I will gain more experiences
and gain more perspective but you know
as of the date of publication here here
are the experience experiences I've had
and then also like
here here are things that I've learned
from like conversing with other people
who I respect who might have more like
hands-on experience with this particular
subject than I do
um so instead of like essentially
rolling that all together and trying to
to
do like what are probably more effective
for the reader
um like narrative based articles where
it's like very argumentative like like
an argumentative essay where it's
essentially you know I I've already
thought through this I know what my
conclusion is and now I'm trying to
build the strongest rhetorical case to
support that like I used to do that a
lot more and I think those articles were
more effective uh like people shared
them more they got more reads like I I'm
I'm actively disincentivized to uh to
present things the way that I do now but
um yeah now now it's now it's much more
so like yeah just just lay out here's
how I came to these conclusions and then
also like here are all of the ways that
I could be completely wrong you know
like if if a study is published that
says XYZ that would that would poke a
big hole in this Theory
um or just like I am assuming f X to be
true but that's unsupported and if it
turns out Y is true yeah this whole
paragraph's full of [ __ ]
um in I do that a lot more now I think
that that that's important
um from just like presenting things in a
in an intellectually honest way
um but also like it's it's bad for
readership so yeah whatever it is what
it is I was gonna say you struck a nerve
with me there because
I've been wrestling with Concepts in
that General
vicinity of like what people say they
want versus what based on Behavior they
actually want versus incentives yeah for
the way you do things and completely
different context but you
look at peer-reviewed research about
meta-analysis about how to I guess meta
research on meta-analysis about how to
do it effectively and say hey
you got to stop oversimplifying we need
Nuance really thoughtful careful Nuance
with your analyzes you know I mean the
methods page of your meta-analysis
should be long that that section should
explain a lot of crap that you're
sorting through uh and then people in
evidence-based Fitness they whenever you
float out a meta-analysis that's overly
reductive in its thinking they say oh
that's such an oversimplification these
researchers don't know anything about
how nuanced this problem is and then we
we published a meta-analysis earlier
this week which is very very thoughtful
in the analysis and very very nuanced
and the journal had a an abstract limit
of 250 words and people were like well
you didn't even explain all of the
analyzes and all of the conclusions in
extreme detail in 250 words so like
what's going on here and it's like well
the more nuanced you get with the
analysis the more real estate you need
to explain it you know and so we're just
kind of caught in this position where
it's like
you guys promised us that you wanted
more nuanced meta-analyzes with more
more thoughtful effort into the analysis
but now that you've been provided it it
seems like that's not what you actually
want because you want something that can
be summarized in its entirety in 250
words yeah uh so yeah sometimes you just
get caught in that place between
incentives what people say they want and
then like you said the actual readership
like what do people respond to well and
there are a lot of times a lot of gaps
in there yeah so now now I'm I'm just
fully complaining but one of the things
that I've noticed that that does that
does really bug me is
um
like yeah I I don't think I don't think
the consumer of
I don't think the median consumer of
scientific Fitness information
actually cares that much about science
itself
um I I think I think most of the time I
think most people who are consuming
Fitness content simply want to be told
what to do yeah and they want to have a
type of evidence supporting those
recommendations that
um comports with their uh
I think just largely aesthetic
understanding of what good evidence is
and so for some people that is
um
it's kind of like a peer-to-peer thing
like like the sort of the sort of Guru
thing so
um they perceive strong evidence to be
you know if someone's been coaching for
a long time and they're good at like
presenting themselves as I am an expert
for them like the the mere
recommendation to do like whatever thing
it is is supported by plenty of evidence
because it's coming from a person who
they perceive to be the type of person
who should be giving advice on that
thing for other folks it's it's just
kind of the classic take advice from the
biggest guy at the gym or just like the
most jacked or strong looking person on
social media for them like whatever
recommendation is given
um is supported by the type of evidence
they care about which is hey if it made
this person super big or strong it must
be good advice because it worked for
them but I I think that a lot of folks
who consume kind of like sciency
information would look at both of those
things and be like ah well there's holes
in that
um you know that that's probably not the
best and most reliable way to come about
like justifiable true beliefs about the
world
um but I I want scientific information
and and that's the the process that I
think is best for arriving at truth but
then
it seems like they don't it seems like
what it seems like what they want is the
exact same thing just someone telling
them what to do and then putting a PM ID
on it or like a DOI
um and just saying like so I I see this
all the time especially on Instagram but
like really just across social media
YouTube everywhere if you if two people
are talking about a study
and one person says oh man like this
this training study happened it compared
you know this one type of training
versus this other type of training and
the first type of training led to 50
larger gains so you should do that type
of training and here's the citation uh
that does really well people people want
information to be presented like that
stripped of all detail and nuance and
zero of them are going to check the
citation to to see whether it even
supports the point being made or to see
if there are any caveats but then like
if you try to do what I would consider
to be a good job of relating that study
and say like hey like here was the
population like the same study was done
it compared like training style a to
training style B here's the population
it was conducted in here was the total
sample size this was the duration of the
training intervention here were the
actual like exercises and sets and reps
being performed here's how they took the
measurements and like here were their
results
don't respond well to that because
because every detail about the study
that differs from their life in any way
whatsoever they view as like grounds to
reject the study treat it as completely
useless and not listen to it at all
whereas if it would have just been
presented the first way completely
stripped of context they'd be like [ __ ]
yeah this is science based I'm gonna do
it
um
so like yeah as as someone who makes
content in this area and like tries to
be nuanced it pains me a little bit
every time I'm typing up like a a
description of a study or I'm like well
I should include this detail about the
study so the reader or listener better
understands what happened in the study
but then I know like if I do it's going
to one just like reduce the reach of the
post and two just like lead to a
shitload of annoying comments like
you're working harder to do worse right
and it's
I I don't know what to do about any of
that but I I do find it very frustrating
yeah yeah I'm not sure yeah we'll have
to brainstorm very philosophically what
to make of that but it does seem to be a
pretty uh a pretty common observation
and and like I said it pertains both to
like you know just putting together an
informative post or even just like
spreading the word about you know
publish research projects you've done
lately uh is uh yeah there's just some
of those gaps between what people
purport to want but then what they
actually seem to respond to well in very
large numbers you know because without
question there's plenty of folks who
love the really nuanced detailed stuff
it's just not the large segment of the
of the readership or population out
there on just on the broader Instagram
uh so the other thing that I guess
that's a good segue there uh probably
the final thing we'll address here
is from Patrick uh and this is
paraphrased I forget exactly where I saw
this question I think this is an old one
that I've just been sitting on for a
while but it was basically you know how
do you go about managing your time on
social media and so like for example uh
scaling up on total time versus scaling
down being more strategic about certain
platforms and how you engage with them I
remember uh yeah now that I think about
it I was paraphrasing this because I
think Patrick asked this question at a
time when you mentioned that you were
kind of scaling social media down but I
think recently you started scaling your
social media up a little bit you
mentioned that you were kind of
dedicated to doing some more kind of
informative posts I think on Facebook so
why don't you take this one first and
then I'll
add to it yeah so for for me like it it
has been a process of
of of being more strategic because like
here's the here's the deal what I want
to do is respond to everybody about
everything like if if someone DMS me and
about just about anything
um I like interacting with people I like
answering questions if someone's just
sending me like a funny video or meme or
something I like those things I want to
look at it and respond and say hey this
was funny send me more like
um
so I have had to cut back severely on a
lot of that
um and it that was a tough decision for
me because like one of I one of I guess
like my formative experiences is like in
early career Fitness professional is
like when I was when I was a young kid
and I was like getting into this stuff I
would like read stuff I'd watch stuff
I'd have so many questions and I would I
would reach out to people
um who who had made the content with
with questions about it that that I just
sincerely wanted to know the answers to
and most of them just ignored me because
I I assumed they were busy and I mean in
hindsight they probably weren't good
questions they were probably very dumb
questions
um but the people who did respond to me
like I I still remember that and it it
mattered a lot to me at the time and so
I told myself like hey when I when I do
this like if I take this route into the
fitness industry
um I I want to make a point of
responding to everyone because like I I
don't want people to feel like I'm
ignoring them
um and like
yeah like I I appreciated when people
responded to me Golden Rule stuff
returned the favor
Etc
um
and like I did that from
2012 until like
last year basically uh like if someone
messaged me about anything or if someone
like commented a decent comment on
anything I wrote
um I would always respond to it and it
just got to the point where
like I still enjoyed doing that but it
it
essentially made it impossible to do
anything else
um like I was gonna say you reach a
point where the time commitment to doing
that becomes
close to infinite right yeah
um and so yeah like it it was starting
to negatively detract from like the
other work that that I could do
um
is you know and it and it uh cut down on
like the amount of content I could make
it cut down on the time that I could
devote to developing products and
ultimately like I'm I I'm a sick [ __ ] uh
with like probably an excessive
um sense of felt Duty and so like if I
did have any sorts of commitments to
like Mass to things I needed to do for
Stronger by science any of that stuff
essentially I would just like devote an
entire work day to just like responding
to people on different platforms and
then instead of like wrapping up work
after like seven eight hours then it
would be like okay now I finally
responded to everyone now it's time to
just start another work day
um and actually like do the productive
stuff I need to do and so it was like it
was like seriously having pretty
negative effects on my health like it
was leading to uh
much less sleep especially during grad
school
um less time to train it was having like
negative social implications like way
less time to spend with Lindsay than I
wanted to and like basically no time to
spend with with any other friends like
it was
it was it was bad for me
um but I felt like I like I can't really
step away because like I feel like this
is the right thing to do and it took uh
it took a lot of work on myself and just
kind of like soul searching to realize
like
no like I can
um because you know there's a finite
amount of time in the day and ultimately
like if I'm trying to do
if I'm trying to do like the most good
possible and have like the largest
beneficial effect for like the largest
number of people
um like ultimately I was I was harming
that by how I was choosing to allocate
my time like you know if I could like
write an article that's going to be read
by 20 000 people versus use that same
period of time to respond to like
150 individual questions over like DMS
to help one person out that no one will
ever see
um like ultimately that that that not
just was a bad use of time for like me
personally and how it would impact the
rest of my life like it meant that like
the
work that I could do that would like
tangibly beneficially affect people was
like more more generally was constrained
um so yeah I I cut back a lot and and
the way that has looked
is
um I I just don't respond to DMs like
much at all anymore that's especially
true on Instagram
um like I
maybe like once a month or two I will
scroll through my Instagram DMS and
things that look like particularly
important to respond to I will respond
and say oh hey sorry it took two months
to get back with you but uh if you ever
want to contact me again don't do it
here here's my email address
um everything else like I just leave on
red and I feel like a dick but like I
kind of have to
um
and so yeah like I I uh keep an eye on
the stronger by science and macro Factor
um Facebook group and subreddit
um I'm trying to make a point of like
posting more consistently on Instagram
and Facebook but ignoring not ignoring
like reading but not responding to the
comments because like if I let myself go
down that road
the wheels are gonna fall off again
um but yeah so it's just been a a matter
I guess of like trying to be strategic
with it and most of what that has
entailed is just like not responding to
nearly as many DMS anymore
yeah
I mean you know me I or or comments on
things that I post yeah yeah
I was gonna say I I really Thrive from
the uh high volume interpersonal
Communications and just the attention
that I get on social media so I'm I'm
posting like crazy and I can't stop
um no I mean I'm I'm very introverted so
uh and I don't have uh
a large group of people kind of
constantly hitting me with DMS so my
my social media experience I think is
very different from yours
um one of the things that I've been more
proactive about managing though with
social media is
um just kind of really spending some
time to figure out how it affects me so
like are there certain platforms where
when I'm on it my mood gets worse like
pretty reliably or are there certain
platforms where people try to lure me
into pedantic arguments that I don't
find enjoyable or fulfilling or even
intellectually stimulating you know it's
like it is different areas in different
pockets and corners of different
platforms you start to get the vibe of
like oh I don't think I like it here you
know and so I've just been more uh more
proactive lately about uh using social
media rather than letting social media
use me and and making sure that when I'm
doing it it's because I like it and it's
beneficial and it makes it makes me feel
neutral to positive you know uh so part
of that's been
um
just being more intentional about how
much time is spent on social media the
other part is just kind of preferring
different platforms over others but uh
you know one of the ones that I really
like is Instagram like I I do answer
Instagram DMS pretty reliably I answer
uh Facebook messages
kind of reliably but I never check that
folder where the non-friend messages go
uh so who knows what's sitting in there
I am do you ever check that thing
um I I peek at it like maybe once a
quarter okay yeah so I have no idea
what's waiting in there for me but
Instagram I Instagram I generally have a
good time on you know I'm looking at uh
you know cute videos of animals and it's
all good I feel like I'm able to curate
a really positive experience there and I
don't get dragged into too many uh
pedantic arguments but another thing
that goes into that though is like you
know you can try to modify and adjust
your social media habits but another
thing is just working on your own
perspective and your own mind right so
if you're constantly getting in getting
lured into arguments you don't want to
be in you do play a role in that you
know like the platform aside you can say
oh I need to be more mindful of when
this is occurring and find better are
ways to Simply opt out of these negative
experiences that I make that sound like
it's like a horrible experience but just
stuff that kills My Vibes that I just
simply don't enjoy and frankly are not
not good uses of my time like we have
enough things we could work on we don't
need to
convince one person at a time to do [ __ ]
they don't want to do yeah that's that's
usually how those those arguments go is
someone says I I don't like eating the
way that that you said would be good in
this article and I'm like then then
don't that's fine yeah but anyway yeah
so I think that you and I are very
different with social media but uh but
yeah maybe those answers will resonate
with some folks out there yeah my
appetite for it is boundless my
enjoyment of it uh
it almost always positive and and so for
for me it's just a matter of like
getting getting myself to do less and
not
it's it's still an ongoing battle to
like not feel like a bad person when I
look at a DM and don't respond to it
like I I do
this is this is probably like an insane
belief I have but I do I do still feel
like it's like if if someone has a
genuine question and I feel like I can
help them out and I choose not to like
that that's feels to me like a bad thing
that I'm doing ethically and that I'm
failing to meet my duties
um
but yeah like I I
every day I think I'm learning to uh
accept it and not not hold myself
accountable for it too hard
yeah it is interesting though like you
said your your appetite for it is
boundless I feel like you're working on
kind of suppressing that appetite or you
know uh you know increasing the
efficiency of how you kind of Leverage
that and with me I'm kind of trying to
drum up more of an appetite for it um
which is kind of a difficult uh
perspective to explain because it's not
that I dislike interacting with people
it's just that my appetite for it like
the I'm on a low volume communication
program yeah you know where like I
really enjoy connecting with people a
little bit Yeah but but when I'm like on
social media and there's just this wave
of communications to me that can be like
kind of almost like a little bit
overwhelming just being like pretty
pretty introverted and not a very vocal
like I'm not a very emotive person I
don't speak a lot uh dude I I think I've
told you when I when I moved out of my
old apartment uh before I did
I mean the walls were like paper thin
like I I can yeah my neighbor I know all
of her Hobbies all of her favorite songs
like it was the walls were just like oh
the sound came through and one day she
asked me she's like what do you do for a
living because I noticed that you were
literally never home and I said I don't
leave like she thought that my apartment
was vacant yeah and I was like dude I'm
here 24 hours a day
um but yeah I just kind of like my
natural default mode is to sit in
silence with no sound and no
Communications whatsoever and for
whatever reason I'm cool as a cucumber
doing that for
a length of time that I think a lot of
people it would actually push them to
the brink of insanity like it yeah but
but yeah we're very different in that
way but it's a weird thing because I
when people reach out to me on social
media I also really value it and I take
that pretty seriously of like I I really
appreciate that people uh like what we
do and would bother to reach out to me
like I don't dismiss that or you know um
I I don't uh lose sight of how uh
supportive that is I don't lose
appreciation for that but yeah I just
have a really limited ability to
communicate at really high volumes so
I'm trying to I'm trying to get a little
bit more active on social media as
you're kind of uh trying to rein it in a
little bit there's plenty of slack to
pick up if you ever just want to log
into my Instagram and uh respond to some
DMS just for practice you know to to
build up that tolerance feel free feel
free
there there are plenty for you I I will
think about that uh and then I'll say no
uh all right so do you have anything
else you want to add in this oh should
we do the the fun one at the end the uh
physical strength one sure yeah
um you were gonna say something else it
sounds like no okay
so to wrap things up here we've got a
question from Hank uh and I think I have
the correct answer so Hank asks uh is
bench press the best gauge of raw
physical strength that's in all caps I
don't know if I did that or if Hank did
that uh and then then the follow-up
question is if not then what is the best
gauge of raw physical strength for me I
would say the pusophel stone carry is
the ultimate gauge of raw physical
strength because you are simply picking
up a giant thing that is uh
inconveniently shaped holding it to your
chest and scampering as far as you can
for as long as you can like to me that
is a thing a very strong person can do
well uh and probably has the highest
level of carryover to like if you just
needed to do some [ __ ] in the world I
feel like the husafel stone carry is as
practical As It Gets
uh yeah I my my thoughts were along a
very similar line
um like I would say like Odd Stone
lifting just generally uh because with
with a husafel it's still like sitting
on on the bottom and like you kind of
hug it and like nurture it up yeah
um but yeah it's like a big gnarly
irregularly shaped rock that you can't
you can't lift in a nice controlled way
as you would an atlas Stone
um but it yeah just just
something where you can't technique it
you know like you can't
um it's not like a barbell you can't you
can't master the technique of just like
picking up very heavy irregularly shaped
objects uh and so I think if you're if
you're very good at that uh you're
probably a very strong person absolutely
and that is uh not where I excel so I
can answer that question without bias
I'm
the the few times I've tried to mess
around with strongman type implements
I've been absolutely useless I think I
could get better uh working through some
some technical instruction because I I
feel like
um every new strong man movement and
Implement is kind of its own little game
where you have to understand the
strategy uh but yeah strong man is not
my not my strong suit Yeah by any
stretch uh all right so I think that
does it for this episode of The Stronger
by science podcast as always thank you
so much for listening and we'll be back
soon with another
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast if you enjoyed the
podcast be sure to sign up for our free
newsletter to get concise breakdowns of
relevant research as well as 28 free
training programs for all skill levels
and all schedules we hate spam just as
much as you do so we'll only email you
when we have something really
interesting to share with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]